bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo sans
plus attendre je vous propose le
générique
[Musique]
j'aimerais vous proposer quelques
photographies alors les voici
[Musique]
il s'agit de l'amazone vous remarqué
sans doute certains éléments récurrents
sur chacune de ces photos est oui
l'amazone est un fleuve qui a une
certaine sinuosités qui serpente à
travers la forêt amazonienne
alors nous allons comprendre dans cette
vidéo pourquoi est-ce que l'amazone
serpente de cette façon et forme tant de
mai en amazonie est une vaste plaine le
relief ne des n'excède pas les 200 m on
est à basse altitude donc ça correspond
véritablement à la définition de plaine
étant donné que la pente n'est pas très
élevé à bien le fleuve va former des
mets entre si une pente est très très
faible il n'y a pas de méandres si une
pente est trop forte on n'a pas de
méandres et si elle fait une certaine
amplitude et bien à ce moment là il ya
formation de méandres c'est ce que je
vous propose de voir et de comprendre
ici en images un morceau de gouttière va
être incliné à différents angles et nous
permettra de vérifier l'apparition de
méandres à certains angles la première
gouttière est incliné à 20 degrés la
seconde à 10 degrés dans la gouttière du
bas avec la pente plus douce on voit
l'apparition de mer entre tandis que
dans la gouttière duo avec une pente
plus forte le tracé est plus rectiligne
il ya d'autres particularités liées à
cette sinuosités du fleuve qui sont les
méandres abandonner alors on peut en
voir quelques clichés il y en à
l'amazone mais on a bien sûr dans
d'autres régions
cbre abandonné peuvent s'expliquer par
l'érosion différentiel que va exercer le
fleuve sur la zone
en effet sur sa rive concave il va
creuser beaucoup plus étant donné que le
courant est beaucoup plus fort à cet
endroit et va petit à petit vraiment
raboter le terrain il y aura
constitution vers cette rive concave
d'une pente plus forte peut aller
jusqu'à être une falaise évidemment
parce que le cours d'eau va se déplacer
et va raboter le terrain de plus en plus
donc il peut y avoir vraiment
constitution comme ça d'une pente assez
forte
de l'autre côté le courant est plus
faible et donc sur la rive convexe il va
laisser le courant va laisser tous les
dépôts que transporte le fleuve donc on
aura d'un côté une vive assez abrupte et
de l'osce une pente très 12 puisque les
a
l'avion se seront déposés
progressivement c'est ce que fait
l'amazone à force de creuser bien
l'amazone va vraiment raboter tout
l'ensemble du terrain et va finalement
rejoindre le méandre le mais on va se
recouper et le fleuve va reprendre son
cours dans le tracé le plus direct dans
le cas de l'amazone évidemment on a
beaucoup d'exemples mais en belgique on
a aussi de très beaux exemples il y a le
cas bien sûr de la semoy qui est un
fleuve un nombreux méandres mais aussi
par exemple la lesse et la laisse qui ne
propose pas mal de de méandres recoupé
de méandres abandonné au milieu de ses
méandres on va souvent retrouvé
détiennent qui ne sont pas des monts
calcaire comme on peut retrouver dans
d'autres endroits de l'inca estienne par
exemple mais qui sont vraiment un
reliquat du recoupement du mélange
j'espère que cette vidéo un peu original
sur la géomorphologie sur l'érosion
fluviale vous aura plu et vous aura
intéressé je vous souhaite une bonne
continuation et je vous dis
chers amis à très bientôt
[Musique]